we are now indeed in the endgame Note
resume wasn't referring to her
Premiership for now I suspected the deal
the PM has brought home was not Yi beef
of merry England but fudge of many
countries the nearly 600 page deal
brexit in name but tied still to
European reality has served only to
unite hard brexit errs and remain errs
in outraged opposition at the time of
recording half a dozen ministers
including the brexit secretary Dominic
Robb have already resigned and it's hard
to imagine others won't follow my
brother Joe quit last week in protest
and characterized the choice as between
the chaos of No Deal and the vassalage
of being out of Europe but still run by
Europe bro Joe was backed up by brother
Boris who ordered the cabinet to mutiny
oh dear oh dear
given this shambles and I'm not just
talking about the family Christmas plans
I don't see how even leave voters can
bear to bleat just get on with it as if
the way forward was easy
let's not for the moment discuss a
people's vote first
MPs must decide if they want a No Deal
brexit or Teresa Mays no brexit deal
which is least bad for the country well
Rachel I think what we should do is pull
out your mobile phone call up both your
brothers put them on loudspeaker and
they can resolve this debate for all of
us here
we could activate the family what's
really weird if George Bush would say in
that we must have had a very interesting
last couple of weeks over that family
dinner table in answer to your last
question there I think that I know
experts have been much disparaged over
the course of this whole brexit campaign
but you know we it would behoove us I
think to remember that people that spend
a lifetime of study a lifetime of
experience and pursue these issues on a
daily basis aka experts are near
unanimity when it comes to
this so-called No Deal brexit in other
words crashing out completely that it
would be disastrous for the country be
incredibly painful even people that want
a heartbreak see I think aren't even
pretending any longer that there are no
deal breaks it would at least for the
short term in their words cause huge
harm can I just interrupt you from on
that because you mentioned my brothers
their point of unanimity one of their
points of fraternal agreement was that
the only good thing about No Deal is
it's not going to be forever but the
alternative which is this no brexit deal
a vassal state scenario with an
indefinite backstop and not quite sure
when we're going to come out of the V or
a customs union
it could be indefinite yeah so the idea
the thing that I think has United both
sides of the Tory party on this the
remain is the ultra Mainers and the
ultra brexit is is this sense that no
deal is terrible it's a cut is a
catastrophe Joe as he said with as a
Kent MP doesn't want can't be the Lori
Park of England but it's a limited chaos
so it's just finished and well that's
precisely why we need them on the phone
because they can know these sorts of
insights but actually I think just on
the final point I was going to mention
on the on the no deal scenario because I
know people are going to be weighing
these up at the moment it's not as
simple as saying let's revert to World
Trade Organization rules because of
course there's a lot to than what are
known as the non-tariff barriers and
that means basic standards need to be
met in products it's not just about
tariffs and taxes to give a very very
simplified example there's a reason why
a toy that we import from any country in
the world today no longer has a spike in
it when you move the head that could
choke a baby right these are standards
in products that we insist that any
products we bring into this country
comply with now on an eu-wide basis
those standards are agreed upon and
that's why we don't need checks the
minute you go to WTO rules we exit from
those agreed standards which means
everything has to be checked even if we
were to agree on the tower tariffs
themselves the maan tariff barriers are
actually the biggest obstacle to trade
and they require years of negotiation so
it would be a really painful thing to to
crash out with No Deal Michelle you've
always said for the last two years white
can't we just get on with it
what's your position now if the if you
were to say that again what on earth
could the Prime Minister be getting on
with
well my position now is nicely summed up
by the front page of The Sun newspaper
it doesn't get us any firm I know you've
known that since January that June the
24th 2016 I am no that's I I hate that
that you would say that the second that
somebody as verted to leave that that is
where the problems have began that is I
really found it quite insulting correct
I don't need to in Cyprus where how
should should we progress the matter now
is what I'm asking you
well first things first you can't you
can't just sit here and go what do we do
today without looking at what's happened
yesterday this whole situation has been
I found it's so disappointing people
have you and your this is the thing like
you're you're almost kind of you're
doing an inhale as though my view is
irrelevant at the end of the day you
know we have been as brexit ears
we have been disrespected our opinions
have been disrespected you're not that
can we not talk about the obvious since
the second this referendum happen and
what has gone on what we've seen over
the last year or so in two years
whatever it's been there's people using
this situation for political gain for
personal political gain
we've seen people backstab make sure we
you'll be doing the show I want you to
throw it forward as a brexit here yeah
what would you like the country to do
what do you want the MPs to do and
December the 10th possibly they will
have to vote on this so that my question
is no deal or do you want resumes deal
yeah we are know is absolutely terrible
we shouldn't be in this situation we are
in a worse situation now we're spending
what 39 40 billion pounds we're tied to
rules without sitting nurse there we're
not going to be able to do our own trade
deals I don't think we're going to be in
a situation where the EU can dictate
when or if we can leave this protracted
customs union or whatever the wedding's
going to be tomorrow and I don't know
what to do next I wish that I could sit
here and say to you the answer and the
solution
can I ask you a question I mean this it
kindly which is a given you've done a
very good summary of the deal which I'm
sure Phil is wanting to come on but wait
just one sec given the deal would you
prefer that we actually didn't leave the
EU now Michelle no I don't think any
circumstances no I think that and this
is where this is the people of back
turns into this corner deliberately
because I feel very backed into a corner
by the shambolic negotiation the
disrespect of people like me position
and I feel that we've been backed into
this corner now of utter ridiculousness
because what we've got now is we've got
a situation which is terrible I don't
think anyone in the land that's apart
from perhaps Teresa Mayer would think
that Teresa made scenarios if Goodwin
and that's the first thing and then
you've got this scenario where people go
oh we crash out of the EU and although
state right now that option has not been
considered in any way shape or form had
it have been on day one had on day one
we actually looked at that as a No Deal
timing had started oh yeah yeah had we
have actually engaged with that and seen
it as a realistic possibility we
wouldn't be where we right now I've got
June gagging to come in Phil I know
you've got something very special but
can we just hear from June Michele
Michele says if Michele says we've got
to just it's all about respect but I
don't agree I disagree they start with
overdue was better than yeah also let's
not forget with the exception of Teresa
may the team the front-facing team that
was supposed to be negotiating our deal
were all breaks of tears and actually
most of them bailed so in terms of the
deal you had your people that were
supposed to be coming up with a solution
that brags the tears would be happy with
and actually in Teresa Mays defense I am
and you know I am no fan of Theresa May
but I feel terrible for her the moon
yeah I do because what can she do right
she knows she's no changed from saying
no no deal is better than a bad deal
yeah a bad deal is better than a no deal
Phil right okay so here it is from the
horse's mouth meet all right
all I'm saying here as a working man
okay who's up this spoon-fed from the
upper classes all his life where I've
been put put upon by people of it
so-called educated all right
I've now read owe you breakfast tonight
I've read it's an absolute dog's dinner
all right the whole thing the whole
thing there's a dog's dinner because
people aren't taking the initial as you
said the initial thing seriously which
was 17 million people in this country
said let's have enough of this let's get
out okay it is true dogs as people
dragged their faith people have stalled
people have come up against it every way
shape and form whereas if we'd have just
unified from the very beginning and done
what was required come up with a
suitable way out of this okay it would
have happened by now it's gonna have to
be a hard deal it's gonna have to be a
heart do otherwise he's gonna be putting
around with documents I don't know -
yeah absolutely
however in my defence in Dunkirk it
worked right bit at Dunkirk spirit okay
we pulled away before is the deal that
in your opinion and yours may be
Michelle's why is the deal that's reason
Mays brought us at this stage is it
worse than it would have been if we just
stayed in it it's worse because people
have dragged at this door and not gone
behind it no no it's not worse to
staying in notaries amazed in Teresa's
might do it is worse than staying I'm
getting out and kept the want to get out
I would crash out yes I would absolutely
break every barrier down and as they
gone any car any cost because once we're
out we can regroup and then we can move
forward again behind it I just wanna
know your opinion and what you think
happens when we crash out I'm asking
your question we crashed out we regain
our own sovereignty we start working
together as a country
Scalzi lujah I do always find is this
the whole dialogue so yeah okay fair
enough you can point out that's that
people are broke cities and stuff the
whole position of our
Constanza for example we'd already
agreed to give people 39 billion pounds
pretty much before we'd even agreed
anything else like why why would you
even accept that as a timetable right
from the get-go so maybe you can sit
down you can say that these people
you're break the tears that were I'm
raising this in this debate now when I'm
trying to raise my thoughts and feelings
I'm tall well that's irrelevant we are
where we are but I actually feel very I
feel very disappointed that we are where
we are I feel like this has been a
almost like a planned tactic to get into
a scenario absolutely I haven't even
Pisa made his period didn't want to
break say the people in the
powers-that-be didn't manager won't
believe you're in charge I'm with you
I'm with you five can we just have a
quick butcher's at what Teresa is
actually saying at the moment I look at
what she said this deal delivers what
people voted for and it is in the
national interest and we can only secure
it if we unite behind the agreement
reached in cabinet yesterday if we do
not move forward with that agreement
nobody can know for sure the
consequences that will follow it would
be to take a path of deep and grave
uncertainty when the British people just
want us to get on with it we've got to
get this thing through now we're going
to get through all right the thing might
not be suiting everybody's tastes but I
think we've got a step back we've got
we've got a regroup and then we've got
to move things forward and reestablish
all these lips all that because we've
broken so much in doing this and there's
so many internal all the all the parties
internally appalled all over the place
at the moment because we're all actually
even though it looks like we're
disagreeing where we're agreeing that
that lot steers a bot right but what I'm
confused about is what do we think
should happen next I could I could quite
openly say I think it's reason a still
should be rejected I think No Deal is as
I've already said a bad option I think
that the only thing left is for the
people to have a say as to one of these
three options but I don't know what I
don't hear anything
yeah so what should happen next I don't
understand I mean if you look at the
numbers as we stand today she's not
going to get this deal
through I have an enormous amount of
sympathy for trees mate I think that
when you know she was never going to be
able to square the circle she has done
her level best as soon as you could
can't have any sort of border between
two bits of Ireland we were going to be
in an extended back stop so what she's
essentially trying to sell at the moment
is that the UK is only a little bit
pregnant you can either be pregnant or
not pregnant so we are in a very binary
situation again and this is why she has
actually United the party in opposition
to her deal and can we just have a look
of butchers as you would say the
brothers and how this is united red Tory
remainders and Tory brexit errs I think
Boris is up first this is just about as
bad as it could possibly be and what
you've got is not only the UK remaining
within the customs union forever in a
day so if you can't really do free trade
deals you can't take back in front of
our laws we remain in a regulatory
alignment with the EU accepting EU rules
unable to shake them I think they should
have some guts and determination and man
up and woman up and and check it out
we're now at the point where MPs need to
take a view is this deal in the national
interest or not and in my view and in
the view I think of others it clearly
isn't it leaves us in a vassal state
client relationship to the rest of the
EU with no say at all over the rules
that will govern a huge swathe of our
economy that's completely unacceptable
and unsustainable for a prior democracy
such as ours I mentioned earlier that my
two MP brothers a agreed that actually
no deal could be better than a bad deal
because it's the time limited but the
difference they have they should they
the difference between them is that Joe
Johnson and P for all paintin thinks
that there has to be the only way out of
the on pass is to have a people's vote
or people's verdict on the deal which I
don't think is going to get through
Parliament Michele I would say because
when you talk about what do we do next
because this is one of the problems I've
had with the whole process everyone
criticizing but no one's coming up with
a proper tangible solution and I'm
thinking themself well what can we I
don't know the answers to what to do
next but if we do what you've just
described and we say right look we've
got this Teresa made thing deal if you
want to call it a I think it's terrible
so you've got the Teresa may thing
you've got what you call crushing out ie
leaving or we've got staying in what
happens then if you put that to avert
and you get 33% on each you have a you
have a senior transfer although there
are ways to fix it however as difficult
as this conversation is it sometimes
when we move to topics like the next one
it just makes puts everything into
context